hey welcome back to my channel my name
is samuel and i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
where we talk about money
marriage and life and in this video
we're going to be talking about
red flag signs in a relationship in a
business
where you know when people just have red
flags about them and you're like i think
this could be bad news
well that is what we're talking about
today things that you need to look out
for
in a potential problem person
do you know any problem people i don't
know any problem people because i
disassociate myself
oh because you see the red flag let's
see the red flags and i
run before we go on to that what have
you been up to this week
this week's been another good week
enjoying the sunshine and yesterday i
had my first girls night
out which was really nice your first
ever all right no no first i guess since
i've had uh baby jessica
okay like in about three four months
yeah three four months but also like
everything was locked down and stuff
before so this was like just you know
is open now outside that was quite nice
enjoying that also obviously usually
kids hanging out with the kids usual
stuff
also has some house viewings for
potential properties that we can
renovate and
you know make look pretty so yeah it's
been a really good week i think that's
great and meanwhile
i've been actually i haven't been out
with you to do some of the property
viewing yeah i know you've been really
busy this week
i've been really i don't even remember
what i've been doing what i've been
doing you
um did some training yeah yeah acnp
accelerated coaching and mentoring
program two full days a small group of
academy members where i basically just
coached them and worked with them that
was
to be fair it was awesome and then i
literally went from that to liverpool
yeah you've been everywhere as usual all
over having me staff meetings and things
like that
so um all right let's get down to it red
flags so
what are some red flags i mean listen
obviously there's the really really
obvious ones okay
like if somebody is a criminal yeah of
course
you say that but to some people i mean
honestly or if they are a
um you know like if if they're violent
if they're really aggressive or or
anything like that they're really
obvious
i don't think we really want to talk
about the really obvious ones i think
it's more about those little little
things that you might not really notice
yeah straight away okay so we've got a
list of a few here
so amanda you go first yes the first one
i would say is
obsessiveness so girls you know like
when you start
when you start dating someone and you
feel like ah he feels like he's always
like you know being all over you
but also doesn't really like it when you
go out and you just kind of think oh
he's a little bit jealous
oh he just loves me oh he just wants me
all to himself like people like that
it's like can be a bit endearing however
it can get
really bad and i think for me that's
like a little bit of a sign to someone
who might be a bit obsessive because
the longer you stay with that person
then the worse it gets and they just
like you you leave the house
they're just like ringing you up so you
know when you're from experience here no
no
no no no no but someone who's just all
over you and
basically just wants you all alter
themselves and then maybe almost
separates you from like your friends and
family tries to isolate you that is like
a red flag
the triangle thing yeah where and also
if someone hates everyone that's a big
red flag yep
oh i don't get on with any of my family
members i don't get on with it i don't
get on with this person don't get on
with that person it's like
but they're obsessed with you yeah and
then suddenly they don't go on with your
family and they don't go with your
yeah yeah it's a red flag so uh-uh
obsessiveness
it's so just what you say as well at
first it could seem fine because if you
start a relationship ah but actually
it's like after a while it's like no
yeah it's like a nunner yeah yeah i
would definitely say that's a red flag
um what's the fine line because
obviously you crave you want
you want to be crazy about your partner
yeah sure
but i mean like for example i went out
last night and
i'd said to you that i was going to go
out for a couple of hours and it was
just going to be dinner and i'd be back
home it wasn't
a i actually got in just before midnight
yeah and i'd left around six o'clock or
something
and you didn't once text me ring me like
where are you but
you know like when are you getting home
like you just kind of let you know let
me be
which i quite like so i think if you
just let someone just have their freedom
to just do whatever because plans change
and things change and like you don't
want someone breathing down your neck
and being like you know timing you oh my
god and like
holding you to when i'm out with some
people certain friends and their their
wives or girlfriends are texting them
where are you
oh you it's just like calm down calm
down
honestly just relax you are a whole
person on your own
yeah you know i don't even like the
saying on my other half because it's
like
it's not mandy's not my other half
mandy's a full person in her own right
i'm my bone person in my right when one
plus one come together it equals one
but that does not mean that we're half
yeah you know so totally agree with that
one
so i want to say a red flag especially
early starts of a relationship and this
is something i actually do in business
as well and that's when they complain
about their previous exes so if you've
got somebody that says oh my last
my last girlfriend was a psycho and huh
the one before that was also a psycho oh
the one before that it's like
there's a common denominator here and
you're
at the center of it you know in the same
way when i'm hiring someone i'll often
ask people i'll say
um if someone's coming in for a job
interview i'll say what would you
what's your previous boss like and it's
like oh he's a nightmare
okay to me that speaks volumes
because number one you don't slag off
your current
or previous boss like that but number
two is
if you think your previous boss was a
nightmare there's just a chance
that actually it's just that you don't
like being
held accountable you don't like being um
given instructions you don't like like
the problem is so often with them
and i think that goes to all
relationships so if ottoman amanda and
she's just been going over how
her all her crazy exes and stuff i'd
have been like i'm gonna step aside
um but that wasn't really the case um so
it wasn't
yeah yeah okay another one for me
is a rebound when someone's literally
just got out of another relationship and
then they just want to jump straight
into it with you
i just find that like really alarming
i'm like uh
what you know what's going on yeah could
that partly be as well you know the
thing i said about being
one person and one person yeah if you
feel like you're half a person
and you need to be in a relationship
yeah when your
partner dumps you or you break up or
whatever
you sometimes are like ah i just need to
be in another relationship you just jump
into a relationship quickly just because
you need that
yeah comfort when actually that's a red
flag because that kind of person you
don't who wants to be with half a person
no um interesting actually as well
confession time
when we met okay april 5th
2014 when we met i had recently
come out of a relationship only maybe
two months
two months i think it was the beginning
of february when i came out of a
relationship
and you were concerned about that
i was yeah i was just like i just asked
samuel out right i just said look i mean
are you serious is this i mean is it
just a rebound situation are you serious
about me
and then you were just like yeah i know
it's definitely not a rebound i just
said
look i'm my previous girlfriend i'm
completely over
there there's no feelings there and and
we spoke about it
and the crazy thing was amanda actually
believed me
not that it wasn't true the reason is
crazy was because the relationship i've
been in and this is another thing
sometimes if you're in a bad
relationship you can bring that badness
into your new relationship
so my previous uh girlfriend man it's
making me sound red flagging
was a little bit of um not psychopath
but was it was a big drama queen okay
in my opinion if you're watching this
hello
um this is many many many years ago not
like a bad person but just just
we were not compatible at all and she
you know was very jealous very clingy
and also constantly you know not not not
like put it this way when you just when
you said to me are you on a rebound or
something and i went no no i'm not and
here's why
and you went okay makes sense yeah i was
like what
because i i've been thinking oh you're
going to ask me this now question is
every day
it's a big thing but if you just well
okay then that's great
i was like oh wow and sometimes as well
not only can
you bring bad bad baggage into a new
relationship
but also like you know in the same way
that
i think you can sabotage a good
relationship because of a previous bad
one like
with it even with amanda for the first
few weeks i was looking for the catch
she's beautiful she's intelligent she's
funny she's smart
she's absolutely perfect what's the
catch
and to be honest i'm still waiting for
the cats
i'm still waiting i haven't i haven't
found the catch yet
but no but you're perfect but i decided
after a few months i was going to stop
looking for the catch because you will
find what you look for
and i thought you know and that's why
the you know the gift where every day i
i found something that i loved about men
of write down
for a year because i actually made a
deliberate decision not to look for a
catch
and again same in business sometimes in
business you're like sounds too good to
be true what's the problem don't look
for the problem look for the solution
so yeah no that's that's true and
i mean the fact i obviously dropped that
and
another thing that i would say is a red
flag is someone who lies you've never
lied
i mean you were honest when you said
that to me and i didn't even have to
tell about my relationship two months
ago
yeah yeah but obviously yeah that's
crazy so
um i think another red flag yet again is
lying yeah whether it's a big lie
i mean or a little lie just any light i
just think it's just like a no-no
because i just think
if someone can just like let a lie roll
off their tongue so easily
i mean i just feel like you don't ever
really know where you stand
dishonesty is just like really
unattractive anyway
so i think if anyone's willing to lie to
you then i just wouldn't i just wouldn't
go there
and also as well even like lying
even joking sometimes i'll say something
to amanda as just a joke
okay so it's so it might be i don't know
i can't think of an example i'll tell
her something oh something
to have a hat just to get a reaction and
amanda a man will say to me
you know do you promise
and if you say do you promise that that
means no joking dude
if i was to then go yeah oh my goodness
no
so because again lion is a funny one i
totally agree with you if you lie about
a small thing you'll lie about a big
thing
um but we kind of have a pack between us
which is because even
like i've had to do surprises for me i
do a lot of surprises for you
and it's really really hard because i'm
doing a surprise for amanda but
sometimes i have to kind of
not lie to her but say something that's
not quite true it's not a lie
off the scenes yeah yeah but i always
dread
her saying do you promise oh no because
yeah no
and over the years we've been married
now what six seven years um
you know we're not only have we never
had um a bus stop or a fallout or
whatever but also neither of us have
ever lied to one another we've always
been truthful and i think the truth
honesty is always the best policy you
know you're watching a movie as well
sometimes and you see them getting
themselves into a real pickup yeah
getting deeper and deeper and deeper
it's like
just come clean and they don't and then
it ends up with something really drastic
obviously the movie like murder or
something
and it all starts with a little lie and
then they just trying to cover up their
tracks it creates more
so sometimes i'll come i'll say to
amanda i'll just i'll
i'll i'll just tell you stuff that i
wouldn't necessarily
you know i might be like look man you
might not want to hear this but here's
why i did what i did or his
and and you come in clean but i'd always
rather do that
than the lie yeah you know and i really
admire that in you actually because
you're very very honest
like really really honest i'm too honest
yeah so like what you see is what you
get with sam you're like literally
serve yeah even in business you know i
will put my cards on the table with with
staff or whatever and i'll just say
even normally when you might like you
might try and i'll just literally
confront it
and that's really really important and
then i think lastly as well and this
goes for business and relationships is
you're going in in a relationship to
give
not to get that's the biggest
thing don't ask what can i get from this
marriage what can i get from this
relationship ask what you can give and
if you both do that that's when you have
a beautiful marriage
or in business don't get a job thinking
what salary can i get what can i get go
to a company saying what can i give
and i think if you have a philosophy
like that
across the board in business in
relationships in finance
even in politics you know i think it was
jf jfk that said don't ask what can i
get from my country ask what i can give
to the country
and i just that's a beautiful philosophy
don't ask what can i get from this world
say what can i do how can i leave the
world a better place how can i
you know i think that's the biggest
biggest biggest thing and that is a
green flag
and the red flags anyone was just trying
to get yeah so on that
basis let's see a few questions or
comments that we've had
from the fans from the samuel and amanda
fans thank you for watching guys
if you enjoy the video you enjoy the
content ask questions
like the video all right so sure now
says i never get over how beautiful
amanda is flawless skin
what lipstick is that i want to buy one
oh no i'm worried
this is not becoming a beauty show oh my
goodness
what lipstick is that it's um it's by
too faced
and it's called lady balls the red one
that's the that's i think
two-faced yeah the brand is called two
face and the color is called lady balls
sounds absolutely dreadful all right dan
streak
says are you both ever thinking about to
buy your own house i mean your dream
house
yes i think at some point we definitely
want to we're already living in our
dream house well yeah we are we are we
are but i mean eventually i don't know
if we'd want to build something
like something different i don't know
but look yeah we're in our dream house
yeah i love this house so much we rent
this house it's beautiful yeah
and and and it's amazing would we
would we buy our dream house probably
not maybe as a manager maybe we'd build
it why
because we want to make money on it
right so all right last question last
question emmanuel says
um amanda how old were you when you
moved to the uk and how long did it take
you to adjust to the english cuisine
also do you cook any african meals at
home has samuel tried and
loved any african dish okay so i was 10
years old when i moved
and english food i mean it was it's all
right it's not that
it's it's probably a bit more bland
compared to zimbabwean food but
i mean it's just it's nice we're going
to an english party right now okay
the food will be very different
sandwiches and whatnot yeah
yeah we tend to do a bit more
little vegetables where you put peanut
butter on there nice
samuel has tried sadza which is like
tried
yes i'm very familiar with africa we're
gonna go to our party right now
mandy final words of wisdom final words
of wisdom okay
success does not come from what you
occasionally do
it comes from what you consistently do
so that's like also just a memo to me
because at the moment i'm trying to lose
weight
and i'm just thinking like why is it not
happening why is it happening and it's
because like oh amanda you had that
donut yesterday
so i'm trying to tell this to myself
like you know i need to consistently do
those things that are going to help me
lose the weight i'm trying to lose the
yeah
subscribe like ask questions before next
time
thanks for watching peace out see you
guys
[Music]
you